you know for a while I thought I was
tars him and I was swinging in the trees
and then I got a hernia and I said no no
no I'm going to be Batman I discovered
some old Batman comic books and a little
shack on the ranch where i live and i
went in and i looked through and i
thought this guy you know i'd love to
play batman and who knew who knew that
45 50 60 years later I would be Batman
and by the way it's all come full circle
because i have my own comic book now the
misadventures of adam west
when we did you know our Batman by the
way the late producer Aras bill Dozier I
think this bread because he came up with
the concept to do it Chuck addition to
make a no Maj if you will to the comic
book and that we were colorful and we
had all the comic balloons a barroom pow
all that stuff but we all got together
and agreed that it should be for the
adults that is the humor and yet the
moralistic lessons and all of those
things and the adventure the splash
should be for the kids so then it
enabled entire families to watch
together I don't like the word campy
because I think it's a word of
convenience and it was used to describe
the prostitutes who followed the Roman
legions in battle yes there were campy
but I felt that our show can't be maybe
that's a term of convenience I think and
without sounding at all pretentious I
think our show was between the lines and
had irony and commentary on what was
going on socially and we've made fun of
a lot of institutions with a
tongue-in-cheek attitude you know
take her up
hey shorty
my favorite Batman episode was probably
the first one because it was all jelly
and I was getting all kinds of memoranda
memorandums from everywhere from people
associated with the show the suits that
hey you're not playing this the way we
thought you would are shut we want you
to be more wooden more square jaw and I
said no no no no no no no and after two
weeks the message is all changed and it
was go ahead and do whatever you're
doing I don't know what the hell it is
but do it and as it kind of worked I
really feel you cannot play down to
these people out here we've got to have
a sense of humor some wet about and then
you know our show lasted this 45 years
since i started
and i still play batman you know around
midnight i'll go out and uh appear in
the fog somewhere pretend i'm batman and
try to save some young mate is that my
wife is off of the power
right our timing was impeccable the luck
of our timing and that it was that
period in our social history you know
the late sixties when things were
happening in the 60s I've read that it
was the 3 b's Batman The Beatles and
bond